Let's do a pomaceous thought experiment to find out
whether the motion of an apple really is somehow similar to the motion of a moon
and if an attractive force could actually somehow produce a circular orbit.
Since this is such a cool experiment, our experimenter gets a suitably cool haircut.
First, she's going to drop the apple.
Well, we all know what's going to happen. It's going to fall to the ground.
Now let's say she throws the apple with some initial velocity--V₀.
Well, we learned in the last unit exactly how to quantify this motion.
The apple will follow some trajectory like this.
Now let's say she throws the apple with a velocity of 2V₀.
Which trajectory best describes the path the apple will take?